اذا منتخب البلد المضيف المنتخب القطري
اليوم يلعب مباراته الثانيه في كاس عالم
2022 امام المنتخب السنغالي بطل افريقيا
والذي قدم مباراه يعني كانت بصراحه ممتازه
جدا امام المنتخب الهولندي نتيجه مباراه
منتخب هولندا مش لازم تغر منتخب قطر لانه
بيكون الامانه المنتخب السنغال كان يستحق
نتيجه افضل من ذلك ربما كان يجب ان يخرج
بالتعادل في هذه المباراه همم المنتخب
السنغالي لديه حلول كثير عنده كثير لاعبين
مميزين لذلك اعتقد انه هاي وحده من اصعب
المباريات راح تكون على المنتخب القطري
همم امام السنغال منتخب قوي بدنيا منتخب
لديه سرعات منتخب لديه همم عنصر المفاجاه
عنده لاعبين سريعين جدا مثل اسماعيل يسار
اللاعب الاخر موجود على الجناح الاخر
وايضا عنده ديه بالهجوم عنده معدل اطوال
عالي جدا حتى دفاعه دفاع طويل ان كان سي
سي او ان كان كوليبالي عندهم همم طول فارغ
لذلك منتخب السنغال منتخب عنده همم ادوات
او عنده قوه كبيره ولكن خلينا نحكي عن
نقطه مهمه جدا هي غياب لاعبين مؤثرين
بمنتخب السنغال وهي نقطه لازم نستغل
المنتخب القطري بشكل كبير لانه عندنا
دياله على الجهه اليسرى لمنتخب السنغال
راح يغيب عن مباراه اليوم بسبب الاصابه
وان لاعب الوسط المشهور جدا اللاعب
كريستال بالاس اللي ايضا انصاف في مباراه
هولندا وهو شيخه وكويته ايضا سيغيب اليوم
عن مباراه قطر وبالتالي هاني نقاط مهمه
جدا لازم يستغل المنتخب القطري وخلينا
نروح بدنا نحكي شويه عن منتخب قطر منتخب
قطر بمباراه الاكوادور قدم مباراه طبعا
كنا بنعرف انه هي لم تكن بمستوى التوقعات
بس بكل امانه اعتقد انه هذيك المباراه
كانت المباراه اصعب للمنتخب القطري بعيده
للمره الثالثه لانه هي مباراه الافتتاح
مباراه الضغط مباراه الامور الاخرى ذهنيا
اللي صعب انك تتعامل معها لذلك هذه
المباراه ربما تكون اسهل ذهنيا اعتقد انه
منتخب قطر تحرر من الضغوطات عنده رغبه
عنده حافز انه عوض جماهيره انه يظهر بشكل
افضل من اللي ظهر فيه بالمباراه الاولى
وبالتالي انا متاكد بنسبه 100% لا 200%
انه منتخب قطر راح يكون افضل في هذه
المباراه ولكن لازم اركز على بعض النقاط
المهمه جدا منتخب قطر لازم يتعامل بشكل
افضل مع عمليه الخروج بالكره لاعبي الوسط
وخصوصا عن نحكي عن كريم بضياف همم وعبد
العزيز حاتم لازم يساهمه بشكل كبير اذا
لعبوا اساسيين طبعا يساهموا بشكل كبير
بالخروج بالكره بشكل اسلس من اللي شفناه
بمباراه الاكوادور الاظهر لازم يقدمه
مسانده اكبر هجوميه لازم يكون في مغامره
لازم يكون في شجاعه اكبر بانك تغامر شوي
هجوميا عن طريق الاجنحه الضغط العكسي همم
على الفريق الخصم مهم جدا ان تلعب قطر
بضغط عالي تحرم منتخب السنغال ان يطلع من
المناطق بشكل مريح نصف ملعب السنغال مش
نصف ملعب مهاري مش نصف ملعب عنده قدرات
همم فنيه عاليه جدا نعم وهم ربما دفاعيا
جيدين وما الى ذلك ولكن
اه عندهم عامل الابداع في نصف الملعب
للخروج بالكره بشكل سلس لذلك يجب على
منتخب قطر انه يستغلها النقطه ويضغط ضغط
عالي على دفاع السنغال وعلى خط الوسط لحتى
يقدر انه يفتك من الكره بمناطق تكون
ممتازه جدا وتعطيه فرصه انه يروح باتجاه
المرمى بشكل مباشر رايي الشخصي مع كل الحب
والاحترام لحسن الهدوس ولكن اعتقد انه حسن
الهدوس اليوم بيبدا احتياطي لانه لازم
يكون في لاعب اكثر ديناميكيه اكثر حراكيه
في منتصف ملعب منتخب قطر وقادر ان يشكل
عامل ضغط كبير جدا على لاعبيه وسط ودفاع
منتخب السنغال على شو راح تنتهي هذه
المباراه هذا امر متروك طبعا مثلا بنحكي
اليوم ولكن اعتقد انه قطر قادر انه طعم
المفاجاه في هذه المباراه وقادره ان اتحقق
نتيجه ايجابيه تعوض فيها جمهور القطري
والجماهير العربيه عن خساره الافتتاح امام
المنتخب
[موسيقى]